if there's one thing people know about
competitive diving it's that the splash
is important
the perfect dive will have the smallest
splash like this highest scoring olympic
dive ever by matthew mitchum from 2008
but
it's not just this that determines the
splash
it's what happens underwater
[Music]
to figure out how olympic divers get
such small splashes i spoke to the guy
who trains them
my name is drew johansen i'm the head
diving coach for the 2020 olympic team
coached in london in 2012 as well
as in rio for 2016.
there's three components there's the
above water
there's the swim and then there's the
underwater sea
divers can't change much once they're in
the air so when they push off they have
to give themselves enough height enough
distance from the board and enough
angular momentum to complete the dive
you know you're going 30 miles per hour
you have all the angular momentum about
four and a half somersaults on top of it
and you're anticipating that moment of
hitting the water
as they approach the water athletes
extend their body into a needle-like
line with their toes pointed knees
locked abs tight arms up and
hyper-extended over their heads elbows
pressing tight into their ears and most
importantly their hands in this position
we'll have the athletes
put their hands out and have them put
their thumbs together in a locking and
then they'll grab on top
this creates what's called a rip entry
named for this sound
and it's crucial for breaking through
the water in a way that minimizes splash
to understand whether's body position is
key let's look at what happens when
you're not in this position if you slip
and fall for instance like chinese diver
chang yani did in the fina world cup
semifinals covered by nbc sports oh my
goodness
splashes come in two parts
the initial splash is unavoidable as
water is getting displaced it has to
move somewhere it gets pushed down and
out creating a radial jet that shoots up
at 20 to 30 times the speed of the
impact
the second part of the splash is caused
by the air that divers bring in with
them
when yani's body makes contact with
water it creates an air-filled cavity
as her body submerges the cavity deepens
and the surrounding water starts
applying pressure
that pressure is enough to cause the
cavity to collapse in on itself
it starts filling with water from the
bottom up
there's so much pressure and energy that
the water ejects straight back up
towards the surface resulting in a
worthington jet the second pop of the
big splash we see here
[Music]
this large splash earned you an e a
scratch dive zero points
just a day later yani was able to create
the total opposite a tiny splash
thanks to that hand position and her
controlled and rigid body
this dive scored 73.5 points
just recently at our olympic trials we
had a 90 point dive actually a couple of
them in there
up on the 10 meter platform
like this dive by team usa member jordan
windall which scored 96 points
as his flat palms make contact with the
water they push it down and out
he still gets that initial unavoidable
splash but it's tiny
the flat hands create a cavity that's
just wide enough for his body to pass
through
the next steps in the rip entry work to
minimize that second splash the
worthington jet and they take place
under water
as they enter the water they're going to
swim their hands out to the side this
swim motion is clear in this 76 and a
half point dive by andrew capobianco
from an olympic trial event in
indianapolis
it moves some of the air brought into
the water away from the center breaking
the air cavity into smaller bubbles
you'll see two white bubbles out to the
side
of the hole that the athlete went in
those are the swim bubbles and then the
final component is is another somersault
that's created under water that also
will trap the air that comes into the
water and prevent it from coming up
through the same hole that it went in
and delays it from coming back up and
that's what reduces
reduces his flash as much as possible
this disperses air breaking big bubbles
into smaller bubbles making them less
splashy when they rise to the top
if performed correctly the bubbles will
be so small that it looks almost like
the water is boiling at the surface
the perfect splash is what appears to be
no splash at all
[Music]
there's no official rules on splash size
in the funeral rule book but judges do
use it to impact scores it'll fall under
the category of overall impression the
judges will look at the technical
elements and they have the leeway in our
our subjective sport when the dive has
that exclamation point on the end of it
it does bring the scores up and it is
within the rules for the judges to do
that getting a perfectly small splash
isn't the point of diving however it is
the punctuation to a job well done
you